[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRENDAN LIM: Hello, everyone.
My name's Brendan Lim.
I'm the product manager on
Cloud functions for Firebase.
Hi, I'm Thomas Boulden.
I'm the tech lead on Cloud
functions for Firebase.
BRENDAN LIM: So let's
get things started.
So, I'd like to kick things
off by telling a quick story
about our friend here.
His name's Frank so
everyone say hello to Frank.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Frank.
BRENDAN LIM: So Frank
is a mobile developer
and he wants to build
a brand new mobile app.
He's tried many
different messaging apps
but he hasn't quite found
one that works really
well for him and his friends.
So, he wants to fix that.
So after spending
countless hours
thinking of many
different product names,
he finally settled on one.
Hipster Chat.
So Frank is determined to make
Hipster Chat the best messaging
app for hipsters.
Now, Frank really
wants to build his app
using Google Cloud Platform.
It just so happens that
Frank remembers that Google's
actually quite great
at messaging apps,
so they must have the
tech to support his needs.
So while looking into
Google Cloud Platform,
Frank discovers Firebase,
Google Cloud's mobile platform.
So he starts digging more into
what Firebase has to offer
and he gets really excited
after he learns about all
of Firebase's great products.
More specifically, Frank's
interested in using
Firebase's back end products to
help him build his app quickly
and easily.
He can use Firebase
authentication
to manage all of his users.
He can use the real-time
database to store and retrieve
chat messages.
He can also use Cloud
storage to store
all those images that are going
to be uploaded by his friends.
So this will save
Frank a bunch of time.
And since he can use
these products right away,
he doesn't have to worry about
setting up his own servers
or building out all these
features from scratch
on his own.
So there is a problem though.
This might not be as easy
as he originally thought.
So Frank mapped out a
few great core features
that he really wants
to add to Hipster Chat.
Many of these
common use cases are
found across many
different mobile apps.
For instance, he wants
to send notifications
when messages are posted
to a particular chat room.
He wants to resize
images after they've
been uploaded to Cloud storage.
He also wants to filter
offensive language that's
written to the database.
So Frank also wants use
data from Firebase analytics
to somehow incentivize
his most engaged users.
So now Frank's a
little concerned
because these are all extremely
important features to him,
and he's worried because this is
becoming much more complicated
than he originally thought.
So let's take one of those
use cases, resizing images.
So sure, resizing
images is actually
quite simple from when
you're trying to create
your own custom back end.
But the issue here
is if he puts it
back in between his
app and Firebase,
Frank loses out on some
of the best features
that Firebase
actually has to offer.
So, Frank's custom
back end will be
able to handle thumbnail
creation no problem.
But he'll have to re-implement
many of the features
that he would have
gotten for free
if he were using
the Firebase SDKs
and communicating directly
with Cloud storage.
One, he'll have to re-implement
rezoomable uploads as well
as rezoomable downloads.
He won't get tight
integration with Firebase auth
to help with end
user authentication.
With his custom back
end, he may end up
having to pay for resources that
he's not actually utilizing.
Now Frank may also have to
worry about building and scaling
a custom back end
from scratch to meet
the demands of his
app, which is surely
going to be a top 10 app.
So well starting today,
Frank can actually
do all of this in Firebase.
So he can do this without
the added complexity
of setting up servers and
creating his own custom back
end.
Best of all, he can
still do all these things
very quickly and very easily.
So today we launched Cloud
Functions for Firebase
in a public beta.
We've been working very closely
with the Cloud Platform team
on this for quite some time.
Cloud Functions for Firebase
provides a first class
experience for Firebase
developers, built directly
on top of Google
Cloud Functions.
So this actually has been
the number one most requested
feature from Firebase
developers and we're
very excited to talk
to you about it today.
So Cloud Functions for Firebase
is our programmatic glue.
It lets you extend and connect
Firebase and Cloud products
to create a completely
serverless mobile back
end for your apps.
Cloud Functions are event
driven, lightweight JavaScript
functions that are deployed
to Google's Cloud which
are executed in a managed
Node.js environment.
So Cloud Functions for Firebase
provides Firebase developers
with a dedicated SDK,
tight integration
with Firebase
tooling, as well as
additional Firebase
specific event providers.
So how does it work?
So as I mentioned earlier, Cloud
Functions are event driven.
You specify the
event your function
should be triggered by.
So first, an event is emitted
from an event provider, which
I'll go over in a little bit.
If these conditions are met,
your function will be triggered
and a new instance
will be spun up.
Then the code within your
function will be executed.
Now within this code,
you can make calls
to other services and
APIs and as a result,
you can choose to
invoke other functions
since some of these services may
actually emit events as well.
So after your code is
finished executing,
your function will
spin down and you only
pay for what you use
with Cloud Functions.
So let's quickly jump
back to Frank's app
and see how he can
actually resize images now
that he has Cloud Functions.
First, you'll notice
that he no longer
has to deal with setting
up his own servers
and a custom back end.
His app can now communicate
directly to Cloud storage
using the Firebase SDKs.
So this will give him
all the added benefit
that we talked about earlier.
So now Frank can
create a Cloud Function
to resize images
that'll be triggered
when any image is
uploaded to Cloud
Storage at a specific bucket.
So he won't need to set up
and manage his own servers,
he won't need to worry about
manually scaling his service
to meet the demands
of Hipster Chat,
and Frank can have a
completely serverless back end
for his mobile app
using Cloud Functions.
And he can still do
everything that he
wants quickly and easily.
And that makes
Frank really happy.
So Cloud Functions
for Firebase has
support from many
different event providers
from Firebase as well as Cloud.
These integrations allow you
to extend their functionality
through Cloud Functions.
So for instance,
real time database
lets you trigger a function
when a write occurs
at a particular path
in the database.
The Firebase
authentication integration
lets you trigger a function
whenever a new user is created
or whenever a new
user is deleted.
The Firebase
analytics integration
lets you trigger a function
whenever a new conversion
event is [? logged. ?]
Cloud Storage for Firebase
lets you trigger a function
when a storage object changes
within a bucket.
Cloud Pub/Sub lets
you trigger a function
when a new message is received
in a particular Pub/Sub topic.
HTTPS functions all you to
expose a unique secure URL that
can be triggered whenever
a request is made.
So now I'm going to
hand it off to Thomas
so we can start seeing
Cloud Functions in action.
THOMAS BOULDEN: Thanks, Brendan.
So, every demo starts with
Hello World and this is ours.
I really love how simple
we've been able to make this.
With just a few
lines of code, we've
made a complete
serverless back end.
There was no configuration, no
rules for scaling up or down.
It just works.
And because Cloud Functions is
on the latest long term stable
release of Node,
it was 6.9.1, we
can use features
of Javascript 6.
It's a Vanilla Node
environment that's
automatically managed for you.
And Cloud Functions
is designed to help
give your service the last mile
customization that you need
and we price it
that way as well.
You only have to pay for
100 millisecond increments
of your code.
But we really love this demo.
It's so simple, we had
to add a space filler
and add a new graphic
showing you that it works.
But screenshots aren't
as fun, so let's actually
go into production.
Can we switch to the laptop?
So, Cloud Functions integrates
with the Firebase command line
tools and it's is
easy to use as ever.
All you need to do is
type Firebase deploy.
This is because our SDK and our
CLI work seamlessly together.
We can load your code and
understand which Cloud
Functions are in your app.
Once we finish
deploying that code,
any HTTPS functions' URL
will be printed here.
We can click and in that
time, Cloud Functions
is able to find or create
an available instance,
spin up your code,
and serve the request.
So now we can jump to
the Firebase console
and check out all of
our Cloud Functions
with a bird's eye view.
This console lets us
see how many functions
have been deployed, what will
trigger those functions, how
many times they've been
fired, and how quickly they're
running.
We can also look at the logs.
And you'll see that there's
a log statement every time
a function is executed as
well as when it completes.
If your function exit because
of an unhandled exception
or rejected promise,
it'll be here as well as
with our integration in
Stackdriver Error Reporting.
If you want to debug what's
happening in your function,
any print statements you
have inside your JavaScript
will automatically
end up in here,
but we also will integrate with
Stackdriver debugging as well.
So let's jump back to the slides
and see what Frank is up to.
Slides please.
Thanks.
So, that was a
basic Hello World.
Frank wants to actually
say hello to the world.
Frank has a dream of uniting
hipsters all around the globe,
but the world speaks
many different languages.
Frank wants his chat
app to let people
communicate with each other
in their own language.
But how can we do this?
Let's start by looking
at his mobile app.
So far, Frank's app
is pretty simple.
There's no chat rooms,
there's just a messages node.
Each message has a
unique ID and there's
a standard field for the text.
You can find out how to
write this app and much more
for iOS, Android, and the open
web on our YouTube video Zero
to App.
But what if we made our app
a little bit more complex?
What if the database already
had translations in it?
Well now we can see that can
very trivially update the UI
so that only renders the message
that's in the user's preferred
language.
But of course, the
big question then
is how do we get the
database in this state?
Well, Google has two great
products that Frank can use.
There's the Firebase real-time
database that he's already
using and Google Translate.
Now Translate does
have an API, but it's
meant for server side use.
So how can Frank use this API
without including a server
key inside his mobile app?
Well we're here at
this talk today,
so I'm assuming you can guess
that it's Cloud Functions.
He'll write a
Cloud Function that
listens to the database
at messages/ID/message.
Now notice the ID here
is in curly brackets.
This is one of my
favorite features
of our integration with
the real-time database
because that's a wildcard.
That means that we will
match on both the left
and the right side
of that wildcard
and we'll capture the actual
value as an event parameter.
This means that a single
Cloud Function has the power
to listen to events
that would have
taken thousands and thousands
of listeners before today.
Once our Cloud
Function is started,
we're going to make a few
requests to the Google
Translate API.
First we're going to ask for
the list of currently supported
languages and then
we're going to ask
for that message be translated
in each of those languages.
As we get results back,
we'll stream them back
to the Firebase
real-time database.
So let's code it up
and see it in action.
Can we switch to
the laptop please?
Cool.
So because Cloud Functions is
a Vanilla Node mod-- or Node
client, we can use Node modules.
You can benefit from the
community of Node developers
out there.
Now our first demo was
written in Vanilla JavaScript.
I'm going to start
writing my demos using
some more advanced
features that are part
of the upcoming JavaScript
7 standard, so I'm going
to use TypeScript to get them.
This will also give me syntax
complete and syntax error
checking.
So first, let's go ahead
and add that Translate API.
So the Google Cloud
Translate library
returns a function that you
should call to initialize it.
I don't have to use
any parameters here.
Because Cloud Functions
is part of the Cloud
Platform and all
Cloud SDKs can auto
initialize inside
Cloud Platform.
This is very useful
for making sure
that your app can use the same
code for your development,
testing, and production
environments.
Now let's write a Cloud Function
that listens to the database.
There we go.
So you'll notice we have a
number of namespaces here.
These are all different
services that we can use
Cloud Functions to respond to.
And a database
will let us listen
to changes on references.
The code almost writes itself.
And we want to have
a write handler.
Now you'll notice because
of TypeScript-- whoops.
There we go.
That we have, if
you can read this,
a function that takes an event
of delta snapshot and returns
anything.
But there's a hint that it
could be a promise of anything,
and we'll get to
that in a second.
So, I'm going to use
an async handler which
is part of the upcoming
JavaScript 7 features.
And first do something
with my event.
So you'll notice that
events have many fields.
These are standard fields
available for every event
you handle in Cloud Functions.
They include what
type of event was
triggered, what resource
fired that event,
and even the parameters that
are the actual values of that
wildcard up here.
The data for each event though
depends on the kind of event
you fired.
For a database event,
it's a delta snapshot.
If you've used the Firebase
SDK for the real-time database,
you're very familiar
with data snapshots.
A delta snapshot is everything
a data snapshot is and more.
So next, let's go ahead and
get the set of translations
or the set of languages
available from Google
Translate.
This function can either take
a callback or return a promise.
And I'm going to
return a promise here.
I can either say then
and continue that way.
But since I'm using TypeScript,
I can just say await.
Now code will continue
after that's completed.
The Google Translate libraries
return an array of two values.
The first is a simplified
value and the second
is the raw values
from the REST API.
Since I only want
the simple values,
I'll do this to extract that.
Cool.
Now that we have our
list of languages,
which are over 100
supported languages,
I want to fire than
more than 100 network
requests off at the same time.
I'm going to need to eventually
keep track of that work so
let's create a temporary.
For each language, I
want to do something.
And because it has that array,
I will extract the first volume.
So now we have over 100 requests
running at the same time
and I will take that value and
save it back to the database.
I'm going to need a reference
to the database, which comes
as part of every snapshot.
There's a dot ref that is
where that snapshot came from.
Now this reference here
is to this message node.
If I want to make
a peer, I'm going
to go up one level and then
back down to the language code.
And set that to the translation.
Now with an async function,
I can either await the result
or just return it.
Now all my work
has been complete.
I just want to make sure that
my Cloud Function doesn't
terminate until all
the requests are done.
So I can create a promise
with promise dot all,
and that will wrap up
everything that's outstanding.
By returning that
promise, Cloud Functions
knows that I have
background work
and it will keep the
Cloud Function alive
until that work completes.
So let's try this
out in production.
It's the moment of truth.
So I needed to have
a write that matches
messages and some value.
This one can take a
little bit like I said,
there is over 200
requests in here.
100 languages, 100 writes
back to the Firebase database,
but there we go.
[APPLAUSE]
So let's switch
back to the slides
and find out what's
on Frank's list.
So, Franks loves
his users and wants
to make them feel
welcome in Hipster Chat.
He hears that bots
are so hot right now.
And so he decides to write
his own, Mr. Mustachio.
Mr. Mustachio's
first task is going
to greet new users in
the general chat room.
Well luckily, Firebase
authentication also
works with Cloud Functions.
It supports two kinds of
events, the creation of a user
or deletion of a user.
Deletion events are
great for things
like clearing out the
profile information of a user
when they leave your app.
But today we're going to
use a user creation event
to give our bot some life.
So let's switch back
to the [INAUDIBLE].
There we go.
So in this demo, I'm going to
use the Firebase Admin SDK.
This is the SDK that
we've written to help
you build a server side app.
And of course we've been
thinking about Cloud Functions
the entire time.
To initialize the SDK, we
need to call initialize app.
And to do that, we're
going to use a feature
called functions.config.
Functions.config is a snapshot
of Google runtime config
from the time that
your app was deployed.
This is a great way to make
sure that your code stays--
or and your config
stay cleanly separated.
This is a great way to make sure
that your apps stay testable.
And we've added a
special variableness
config called Firebase.
This is automatically
populated and has
everything you need to
initialize a Firebase app.
So we're going to create a
new Cloud Function, this time
integrating with Firebase Auth.
We're going to listen to
a user event, specifically
the user creation event.
Now this time, the event
data is a user record,
which makes sense because a
user record is what is returned
when you call create user.
Now in order to write
a message, we're
going to need to push a new
value into our database.
Here, we just have the text
of the most interesting part.
We're using the display
name from that user record
to make sure we greet the user.
The rest of this
here is part of our--
how we actually inform
our UX to make sure
Mr. Mustachio is
visible as a bot.
So let's see it in production.
And watch how fast it was, too.
Say let's go back to slides.
So some time has passed.
Hipster Chat has been growing.
It has so many users
in so many rooms
that Frank now needs
to add a feature
to let people get
others' attention
if they're subscribed to a room
but not currently reading it.
So he's going to
add @here mentions.
Frank does a little
bit of research
and he knows about
Firebase Cloud Messaging.
It's a cross-platform
product that
lets you send notifications
across iOS, Android,
and the open web.
But there's only one problem.
He looks at the
quickstart sample
and sees that there's a stubbed
out message called send token
to server.
That's because
until today, you've
needed a custom server in order
to be able to programmatically
send notifications.
But not anymore.
See, Frank is clever.
He knows that the
Firebase database has
very flexible security rules.
He can create private
areas in the database that
are restricted to each user.
And so he's going to implement
his send token to server method
so that it pushes a device
token in an area that
is based off of the user ID.
Now he has secure storage
for all his device tokens
and he can let Cloud
Functions do some magic.
Now we're going to break our
push back end into two parts.
Rather than looking up every
device token for every user
that's in the topic--
or in the room whenever
you get an @here,
we're going to have a
subscription management
piece in the part that
actually does the sending.
This is the first part.
We're going to
listen to the change
of all users in all rooms.
Whenever we notice that a user
has joined or left a room,
we're going to subscribe or
unsubscribe from an FCM topic
respectively.
This will dramatically simplify
our push code because now we
can just scan messages.
If they contain
an app mention, we
can send a push notification
based on a topic corresponding
to the target room.
So, let's jump
back to some code.
To bump the difficulty
one more time,
this demo is actually going
to use raw HTTP requests.
So I'm going to add
yet another library.
So, that first function
was a database function.
I said for every room
wildcard, every user wildcard,
we're going to
listen to any write.
Now that could have been a
user insertion or deletion,
so we're going to find out
which and map it to the actions
that Cloud Messaging
supports, either a batch add
or a batch remove.
Next, we're going to
need the list of devices
that are associated
with this user account.
So we're going to use
the Admin SDK again.
We're going to look up the
values in that private storage.
Now it's possible a user doesn't
actually have any tokens.
For example on
iOS, the user might
have disabled
notifications altogether.
So let's check for that first.
If the snapshot does not
exist, the user has no tokens,
we'll log a debug
message and exit.
Otherwise, we'll log a
different debug message
about how we're adding
or removing tokens.
Oops, jumped ahead of myself.
So since we're
making HTTP requests,
we're going to need
to authenticate it.
For this, we're going to look
at that Firebase config again.
See, part of that
Firebase variable
is the credential
that the SDK itself
is using to authenticate.
And that credential
serves [INAUDIBLE] tokens.
So you can get the
same cacheable token
that we use if you're making
any requests to another Google
service.
Now all we have to do is
make our HTTP request.
We're going to send a
post to this address using
the action we decided earlier,
either batch add or batch
remove.
To authenticate, we'll
add some headers.
And then our body will be the
topic that we want to modify
and the list of
tokens we want to use.
So this could be a full
subscription service.
As an exercise for
the reader, there's
some other stuff you can do.
For example, this
method has return value
and contains an array of a
list of objects that correspond
to either success or an
error if that token was
expired or invalidated.
But now with our
subscription service in hand,
we can try push notifications.
We'll write another
database event handler
where we listen
to the text field
of every message in every room.
Now if there was no @ mention,
which is fairly common,
we can just early exit.
This is a small--
or a simpler version
of what we did before
where we console
logged and then returned
because the return
value of every function is
logged in the Google Cloud
logging console.
So next, we have the
room ID from this event.
That's a stable identifier
but it's not human readable.
We actually have a title
for our various rooms.
So we'll use the admin
SDK one more time
to look up that room's
title based on its ID.
Now we'll construct our payload.
We're going to send the
message to a topic based
on the room ID and a message
that includes the friendly room
name.
And then we use the messaging
features inside the admin
SDK to send that message.
So, let's go ahead and
see it in production.
[INAUDIBLE] I missed it.
There we go.
Serverless push notifications.
[APPLAUSE]
And let's go back to slides
for one last scenario.
So, Hipster Chat
has been growing
and Frank has his
eye on quality.
He's hungry for
insight so he uses
Firebase Analytics to learn
how people use his app.
He's so hungry for
feedback that he
added a feature where his
users can fill out a survey.
He's hungrier still, so he
even has an analytics event
to track when people
fill out the survey.
And maybe Frank is just hungry.
Frank was in his coffee shop
munching when he had an idea.
He wants to incentivize people
to fill out this survey,
so he's going to
have a giveaway.
His favorite treat
of vegan gluten
free kale muffin to
the next 12 people
who fill out this survey.
There's a number of reasons
why Frank has already
marked the feedback sent
event as a conversion event.
For one, it lets him
create a user funnel
so you can see what actions
lead people to actually fill out
surveys.
Next, he can use this to
create an audience which
lets him understand whether the
people who fill out his survey
are actually representative
of his normal demographic.
And starting today, Frank can
listen to this conversion event
with a Cloud Function.
So let's jump back
to the laptop again.
So for our last
function, we're going
to create an analytics
event or analytics function.
So we're listening to
the analytics service
and for the conversion
event feedback sent.
This is not a built
in conversion event.
This is one that Frank
has created on his own
and marked as conversion.
Whenever that event is
logged, this code will run.
So in this case, the event.data
is the full analytics event.
Because Frank had used
Firebase Analytics.SetUserID,
this analytic event has
the actual Firebase user
ID of the person
who sent feedback.
This is really
important because now he
can do things like look
up profile information
or in this case,
give the user a gift.
Since Frank only has 12
muffin's to give away,
we're going to add people to the
muffin club in a transaction.
Now, first he needs to
check whether or not
he's already given
away all his muffins
or if he's already given
this user a muffin.
So if he's given away 12
muffins or he's already
given this user a muffin, just
exit the transaction early.
No harm, no foul.
Otherwise, we'll
log that we're going
to try to attempt
to give away him
often and add this user to the
muffin club in our transaction.
If it succeeds, we'll get a
result that says committed.
Otherwise it will
retry and will either
try to modify again or find
out if the last muffin was
given away and early exit.
To figure out which
is which, we're
just going to have
a debug statement.
So once again, let's
see it in action.
So let's get feedback.
I'm being soft on myself.
I may not have put
this one in debug mode
so it might take a little
bit for the conversion event
to come through.
Let's watch.
There we go, muffin club.
So now I have decided to give
myself a gluten free kale
muffin.
So thanks.
I think Frank is pretty set, so
let's hand it back to Brendan.
[APPLAUSE]
Can we switch back
to the slides?
Thank you.
Thank you so much, Thomas.
That was great.
I'm kind of hungry now, too.
So to recap, Cloud
Functions for Firebase
is our programmatic glue.
You've seen how it lets
you stitch together
Firebase and Cloud products
to create your own serverless
mobile back end.
So before Cloud
Functions for Firebase,
Firebase developers would have
to set up their own custom back
end solutions to do
many of the things
that Thomas went over today.
So your mobile app would have
to connect your own API, not
allowing you to take
advantage of all the things
that the Firebase
SDKs have to offer.
As a result, this would
increase complexity and time
to implement the
core features that
are already available for you.
So with Cloud
Functions for Firebase,
this is no longer the case.
You get to tie together the best
parts of Firebase and Google
Cloud to create a completely
serverless mobile back end
and you still get
to use the Firebase
SDKs in your mobile app.
There's no need to manage
or set up your own servers.
There's no need to worry
about scaling up or down.
There's also no need to
pay for the resources
that you aren't utilizing.
So we've seen a couple examples
of how you can stitch together
Firebase and Cloud products to
easily create powerful Cloud
Functions.
You've seen how to reengage
customers through analytics
using conversion events,
send notifications using
the real-time database
and Cloud messaging,
and how to automatically
translate messages written
to the real-time database.
So Firebase developers now
have a completely serverless
back end solution.
Companies like Sony are
building amazing things
with Cloud Functions
for Firebase
and we can't wait to
see what you build.
You could even start using
it right now for free
on the Firebase free tier.
To learn more you can go
to g.co/firebase/functions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]